لقد اتخذوا الآن
قرارًا آخر وغيروا
رأيهم ونقلوا القضية إلى المملكة
العربية
السعودية والجميع يعلم أنهم لن يفعلوا
شيئًا ولن نحصل منهم على أي خير ،
لذلك لم
أفعل شيئًا بسبب الحكومة
بسبب تركيا.  لأنها كبلد ،
سأنتقل الآن كشخص ،
لذا فهذه هي القصة أحيانًا عليك
أن
تفكر فيها
أه إذا كنت تؤمن
بشيء وستكون
وحيدًا وهذا ما تشعر به أنك
وحدك تقاتل من أجل العدالة نعم
نوع من  ربما تنتهي القضية في طوكيو ،
لكننا نأمل أن نذهب لتقديم طلب
استئناف ، أعني
الاستئناف
لأنه مخالف للقانون ، فهو
مخالف للقانون لأنه لا يوجد
أي اتفاق بين المملكة العربية السعودية
وتركيا وبسبب الكثير من الأسباب
التي لا يمكنهم
اتخاذها  هذا القرار
ولهذا السبب سوف
نذهب للاستئناف